hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the Woodland podcast with of course
another absolute lad and speaking of
leads it is New Zealand cup week which
is one of the best weeks in sport here
in New Zealand and this cat week there
is only one man to follow and that is
the great Reagan Todd Champion harness
racer of the Great Water lad big
supporter of the podcast and of course
he is a LED and he's even sent through a
couple of specials for us to follow this
week to get you going firstly Tuesday
Coro Valley start a place get on that
and on Friday trentress gow each way all
day enjoy and make sure you go give
Todd's racing a follow another thing
that will get you through cat week is of
course pure Sports CBD I'll be doubling
my dose of clarity oil to give me the
clearest mind possible this week I'll
also be carrying my Boost nootropics for
when I need that natural boost of energy
and as always I will have my muscle bomb
on hand for any muscle aches I may get
remember you can get 20 off your order
by using the code what a lead 20 and as
always I leave a link below so if you
are interested on getting some pure
sport CBD go and click on that lastly in
between days this week there is no
better place to clear your head and
refresh your body than o studio and my
man Tim Bateman is giving what allowed
listeners a chance to own your very own
the wellness space is the second fastest
growing industry in the world and it's
only going to grow more as there's more
research done on the benefits of some of
the key parts of our studio Timmy will
guide you through the process of running
your very own business and if that
interests you at all I strongly suggest
that you get in touch with him and
discuss all the options possible again
I'll leave a link below so go click on
that to inquire and as always very
grateful for the sponsors of today's
show but let's get to the show
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]
I would have led and what a lad I have
for you all today was arguably one of
the greatest dual code Internationals we
have ever seen he's a Melbourne storm
and kiwi legend in the 13-man code and a
North Harbor Auckland blues and all
black legend in the 15 aside game he's
also a very highly requested guest
because he is indeed one hell of a lad
it is one of the greats Matt Duffy
welcome mate what an intro thank you
very much don't I don't know about all
that legendary stuff but yeah I'll take
it right claim it mate it's good to get
you on I know I've been trying to get
you on pretty much since you decided to
hang up the boots so um you're probably
a little bit deeper into your post-40
career already so how are you finding it
I'll be honest it was it was quite a
quick like in the scheme of things it
wasn't something that I sort of goes oh
this is my last year and you know I'm
gonna hang up the boots at the end of
the year it was
it was more or less sort of came to the
crunch time and made a decision over
sort of two three week period
um and then the last week when I
actually made the decision I I was stuck
inside with covert with my whole family
so
um yeah it was it's been a pretty
enjoyable couple of months actually
since since hanging up the boots yeah
I'm enjoying it it's good so what was
the deciding factor for you to call it
quits yeah probably I didn't really have
sort of
you know that oh Now's the Time I you
know players say like oh I knew I was
ready and stuff because you know sitting
here today I feel like I could still
play so
um and I and I was still contributing
and it still felt I've still felt good
you know physically and stuff but I
guess
um
when when the rollerman now so came up
you know initially I was you know I was
a little bit gutty because I was like oh
I want to keep playing for another
couple of years and you know it's
probably not the right timing and and
all that sort of stuff for me but
um the further along the
you know the process I got it was just
pretty obvious that it was a massive
opportunity and something that she would
have been stupid to turn down especially
being at the club that I'm at now and
the role I'm in now it's just it just
seemed too too good to pass up so you
know it was
some people go yeah I'm done you know
I'm done I'm finished but I wasn't
really like that and that's maybe what
made it a little bit more difficult to
make the decision
but once I did make the decision I was
completely fully happy and content where
I'm at right now because I knew that
stepping back into the Into the Storm
you know it's just a great setup whether
you're a coach or a player it you know
it's not like I'm going ah bang my head
against the wall art and I should be
doing this or should be doing that you
know it's just it's a it's a great place
to to be did you hear offers from in
Japan still to continue to play over
there because obviously a lot of guys
sort of get stuck in that trap the Yen's
so attractive one more year what's one
more year I may as well keep going
um did you still have that offer well
yeah that was the tricky thing as well I
didn't um so Honda Honda they punted me
um I was I'm a I'm a cat player so I was
when I was over there I'm competing with
you know current All Blacks current
wallaby players current spring box you
know and I'm not a I'm not a 10 I'm not
a 12. you know there's very certain
Internationals they go after so
it was always a battle
um so Honda went weren't um reciting me
so I probably I feel like if I had
waited you know wait until even until
this point this probably still plays
getting signed up over there but in gone
to one of the smaller clubs maybe I
could have done it but then there's a
thing like the storm needed an answer I
could have said no and then rest rest it
but and then also going back to New
Zealand I know I mean the NPC was
it was real it was a really a really
strong competition at the moment I think
because there's a lot of guys coming
back from overseas
um and then there was also America there
was an option uh but again it would have
all been
say no
so I've got this great opportunity
say no and then
figure it out after and you know when
I'm sitting there and I've got like a
one and a three-year-old daughter and my
wife we've been traveling since we left
Melbourne it's been seven years kind of
weighing it all up I'm like man you know
it's not like I'm going to be unhappy
you know it's not like I was gonna I
don't feel like I've sacrificed too much
by retiring you know like
I'm I'm still fitting healthy and I can
play other sports in it you know I was
even training on the other on the
opposition team pretty much the whole
year
um for still running on the wing just
plugging plugging gaps where I could
um but yeah it was it was quite a
complex decision but I feel like in my
head
you know when I really sat back and
thought about it it's just it's a bit of
a bit of a no-brainer really
um and the thing is I do feel like this
is not like a short-term thing for me I
feel like we my wife's from Melbourne we
wanted to move back here
um and settle down so then I literally
can walk back into a job back here and
it's just
and it doesn't feel like a job so yeah
so mate what is your role exactly yeah
so I'm I'm Pathways coach so that's my
title
um so I'm predominantly looking after
the 18 to 20 21 year olds that we've got
contracted
um some are here with us and some aren't
so some are in different parts of the
country and
um
so it's it's pretty cool role actually
like I um like it's a bit technical
tacticals but like the coaching stuff
but a lot of it's going to come down to
sort of that mentoring and I've
literally come through the same system
as as these guys are coming through so
um albeit I came through with the Toyota
cup the Toyota Cap's not round anymore
but we're looking to create something
similar down here so
um it's pretty cool but and the another
cool thing is I'm actually based at Amy
Park and I'm I'm in with the NRL coaches
so
I'm not necessarily an NRL coach but I'm
in the same office
um
listen to the way they talk and and all
that sort of stuff and then I've given
that feedback down same same terminology
and all that sort of stuff so that we
just get this
um sort of aligned process and these
guys coming through the last few years
we've I think we've our development's
dropped off a little bit and it's a
little bit to do with covert but
um you know when the storm were good
like in 2017 is one of the best teams of
the NRL era
um we had we had like I think it was
something like 70 75 of the of the team
was developed in Melbourne yeah you know
and then we only recruited like three
players outside of the outside
um and when I say Melbourne we we don't
really produce many Melbourne players
you know so so malvernians we don't
produce we've only produced four and
like 230 odd players
so the the Melbourne developer players
I'm talking about are the ones like
myself who came straight over from Saint
Kent's
um came over as 18 year old but I'm I'm
a Melbourne player you know what I mean
yeah so we're trying to get back to that
um I think it's really important you
look at sort of Pinterest the way
they're doing it uh we just need to sort
of clean up our pathway so and then
another part of my role is that we've
got like bigger development squads and I
couldn't they've got their own coaches
uh but I I'm sort of
overseeing that and making sure the
processes and and all that sort of stuff
at that level are good so then yeah I'm
a resource for those coaches so talking
about
again trying to same terminology you
know same mindset you know creating
storm players through our pathway so
it's a pretty cool role the leggett's
got all the inner I'm literally at every
NRL session so it's good
mate that is Hawaiian is it mainly on
field stuff sounds like it's mainly like
technical tactical stuff or is it like
off-field stuff sort of like that PDM
type role here yeah yeah so
um I imagine my role you know like I
started in July and so I'm kind of just
getting my feet under the desk and stuff
so I'm still figuring out how it's all
going to work but I think once the
preseason starts what I'm going to find
is it's going to be probably half of
it's going to be technical tactical and
then half of it's going to be creating
good habits like lifestyle habits making
sure these these guys are
eating well sleeping well you know doing
the right things off the field and just
creating habits that are going to help
them have a long career in the NRL so
that's kind of my role as
and the good thing is is that because
I'm not coaching a team I'm coaching
individuals
the pressure of wins and losses is not
really there yeah you know so I don't
I'm not going to sort of
um skip over something because I want to
get a win which can happen at times it's
really going to be great good habits no
matter you know what's happening
and then when they go back to play Under
21s and there's a different coach he
he's more worried about the you know the
wins and losses yeah so it's good it's
really really good way to sort of get
into it um
because yeah you can see
every coach with the best best laid
plans are all great until there's a
couple losses in a row and then you
start jumping on carpet Bubbles and it's
popping up somewhere else and you know
so
um yeah so and you mentioned um being in
with the other coaches what what are
they like what's what's Craig Bellamy
like
no he's good he's he's
um he he's a creature of habit like you
know I left in 2015 and you know came
back sort of seven or eight years later
and and you know I don't see a whole lot
different in terms of his process
throughout the week with his footy
but I think the biggest change I've seen
he's
probably not that he wasn't connected
with the playing group but he's a lot
more connected with the playing group
now than when I left maybe that was just
my perception you know I was young when
I was coming through and sometimes
you're a bit nervous you don't really
have those conversations but I I see now
that how much he's grown in that area in
terms of you know looking after players
off field and making sure they're going
all right and stuff like that so I think
his footy process is is the same
okay I'd imagine he'd do oh he does you
know hours of video even even at the
moment like even now after doing it for
20 years he's
he's still a motivated hard working as
ever and I just think yeah in terms of
the way he interacts with players he's
he's grown a lot in the area so it's
it's good right and there's any players
that you're working with who you're
excited to see or you think are about to
be you know the next uh Matt Duffy's of
I've heard and having as many injuries
as me but uh now there's there's a few
exciting players you know we've got a
good mix coming down in November there's
an exciting hooker coming coming through
Gabriel satrick he um
oh yeah he just burst out out of nowhere
this year and he and he's won he's like
Aussie school boys hooker
um he won like man of the match in the
National final you know his score of
tries you know he's freak freak and he's
up he's from
this Aboriginal Community Way up north
yaraba
um so you know guys and he's a good he's
a good kid loves to compete and he's
funny in it so I'm excited to see how he
develops but
you know it's always hard at this at
that age you kind of don't know
you don't know who's going to kick on
who's not you know it's it's one of
those things but that's the exciting
part
and again for my my role in particular
it's
um making sure they're doing you know
all the right things in the gym off the
field you know all that sort of stuff
and turning up with good mindset
um exposing to mental skills all that
sort of stuff that is going to actually
help them have really long careers you
know so it's really exciting mate and
you're the perfect man for that role
it's exciting times for the storm but
overall ball careers don't really get
much better than
um yours so we do have a lot to get
through I'm looking forward to hearing
it but as always we do need to start at
the start where'd you grow up what was
what was your childhood like yeah so I
grew up in Auckland
um in pakuranga I played rugby and
League all my life so I sort of they'd
ask me at the start of the winter my
parents they'll be like already on a
plane I'd play you know either go down
to the league club or go to the Rugby
Union club and when I was 12 I moved
down to Christchurch I lived in a town
called kaipur with the um
for three years the great met Todd was
from there and um
he was the absolute Superstar down there
like he was literally the king of kaiboi
playing Prem rugby when he was like 16
dominating
um so when I went down there it was
again rugby and league league on Sundays
rugby on Saturdays played a bunch of
volleyball when I was younger loved it
and then when I
um I came back up to Auckland for my
year 11 year so
um and went to Saint Kent so I was lucky
enough to get a
um a bit of a scholarship there so I
went back to Saint Kent's and then
um family all moved back up and then
yeah kind of finished my schooling there
and as soon as I my last day of school I
had my last exam and then two days later
I moved to Melbourne so I didn't stay
around for graduation nothing
um right
so yeah was your was the move purely for
rugby is that what you got your
scholarship for because Boyle accounts
you were you were pretty gifted at
pretty much every sport you try
um oh I think the the actual definition
of the scholarship was a sports
scholarship so it wasn't necessarily for
rugby it's quite funny I turned up I
remember turning up like the first week
at Saint Kent's and um and how like you
know how these things that all the
rumors started oh we've got this kid
from Christchurch coming apparently he's
like a big big sort of um toggle number
eight is like it dominates and stuff
he's coming up from Christchurch and I
turned up mate and I had I had like a
big big Blazer jacket because like you
know just getting the uniforms expensive
and that my scholarship didn't cover the
uniform so mum got me a a Blazer that
would literally still fit me now it'll
still hang off me now and I like turn up
and I'm at the in sort of a couple days
went by the then everyone started to
tell me oh yeah we thought you were like
this big number eight and I'm like
all right yeah we'll see
but yeah and then when I got to thank
cancer
um I'm sort of I'm glad I came through
that same kids when I did because
um
we were allowed to play every sport any
sport you know as long as you could
manage it you know work workload wise
and schooling and stuff you could just
play and soft you know Athletics
volleyball
um we had a cricket a social cricket
team had Rugby Union played softball you
know and that's the same as what I was
doing in Christchurch it's like in
Christchurch town the country you just
play everything you know
ride your bike to training and I thought
it was to me it was great for my
development in terms of just being in
team sports no matter what it is and
it's pretty sad nowadays like the boys
get you know they're doing pre-season
for rugby at like at school it's just
like what is what's that all about you
know like they should be playing cricket
and you know should be playing touch
footy and stuff over the summer and just
you know so I'm glad I came through when
I did because I think if I came through
now I'd yeah rugby would probably give
me the [ __ ] so was it were you training
hard or like were you just pretty
naturally gifted and like you say was it
just because you're playing so many
different sports that you felt like you
were able to pick up rugby pretty quick
or be so good at rugby
um I always I've always been a good
trainer like when I'd go to training and
stuff and the fact that I was playing a
bunch of different things up I wouldn't
need to do anything extra outside of the
actual training so you know in a week
um I would have had I was playing sort
of Club volleyball outside of Saint
Kent's I was playing Saint Ken's
volleyball and playing rugby at the same
time and then sometimes overlap with
Athletics and so in the training or in
the competing part I'd always you know
rip in and stuff but outside of that I
wasn't
like yeah surprise surprise I hated the
gym
um I yeah I didn't I wasn't a big gym
guy so I never went to the gym and it
came back to bite me once I got to the
store I am
and then I I remember literally remember
going for like one run when I was
outside of school when I was at school
like a one road run and other than that
I was just I just loved playing you know
being a part of the team and even
Athletics is like you know you're just
competing you know it's I enjoyed
everything about that and the training
was fun as well you know get down to
training and throw a footy around and
stuff and was it high jump and long jump
that you were good at at Athletics or
what were your events
um
yeah I think oh I think Athletics I was
that was something that I never trained
for because you don't really have team
training
outside of Athletics like for a school
normally they're good Athletics people
would be doing Club Athletics and stuff
like that they have coaches and stuff
but I I guess like Athletics I was
probably reasonably naturally gifted
like I I'd always because I was playing
volleyball I loved the jumping stuff you
know high jump long jump triple jump you
know I loved all that
um and I'd kind of just figure it out on
the Run
um never really had a marked out run up
for long jump or whatever so I think I
guess for athletics I was probably I was
lucky that it clicked for me you know so
um but yeah I reckon with Athletics I
was probably better when I was about I
think I was jumping the same for high
jump when I was about 15 than I was when
I was 18 because I like I think it was
virtually the same because you know I
was getting bigger so I wasn't jumping
as high and stuff like that so but I
think in terms of my best my best event
maybe probably the 200 maybe maybe I
don't know it was yeah I was a high
jumper would always be all right but
there was always some freak who would be
jumping 10 15 centimeters for uh higher
or stuff like that or even long jump you
get the 100 meter sprinters and that'd
be
that'd be yeah crazy good um 200 wasn't
too bad because it it's you know a bit
of a gut run
so not as technical maybe I could make
up make up there with my long strides oh
good stuff but I've always been
interested in like sort of the process
of the recruitment from the storm so
obviously the storm do pick you up
um how was that whole process did they
just watch you playing rugby for Saint
Kent and approach you what how does it
work
um so at the time when I was coming
through where the Toyota cup and that
was NRL like I know this now but the NRL
just was like throwing money at it you
know trying to get it off the ground
Zone
uh when I got signed up like obviously
there was a lot of money coming into the
game like at on 20s level
um and then and with the storm because
they had to recruit a lot of guys from
out out of town and and stuff like that
they I don't I don't know but they
probably got more money than that so I
ended up
um getting recruited after playing the
same kids yeah like I
was a little bit on recommendation like
you know
um kind of like a CV I like this is what
I've done in all different sports and I
think at the time storm really liked
people who had
played a bunch of different sports you
know I think
that recruited that way in the past
because they knew that you get an
athlete in and and sort of a good person
so good character athlete then they can
the system turns them into
good rugby league players and and I
think to be honest that's the way they
recruit now if you want you want good
people good athletes and then the system
will will do the rest so I was fortunate
enough I got a three-year contract while
I was at school so I was one year I was
still at school so I was a scholarship
so it's pretty much nothing it was just
they see me like a bag of Kit which Ross
pumped about
um and then that was in 2008 that was my
last year of Saint kittens and then I
knew that two years after that I was
playing under 20s but it was literally
five grand so my first year was five
thousand dollar contract but you got
your uh but it was you're training it
after out of hours so early in the
morning and then late at night so you
could have a job yeah and then I got my
accommodation paid for by the NRL so at
that time if you live 200 K's away from
your home if you moved 200ks then that'd
pay for your accommodation I think it
was about 200 bucks a week so
I'll say that's how it kind of all
worked out and
um yeah I had a player agent at the time
and
um he sort of said to me that
your best chance of succeeding is going
to storm you know if you want
I think a lot of Agents should really
have that mindset with all their players
you know send them to a good system in a
good environment
and you're going to have a long career
so and that's probably my advice to a
lot of young guys if you know if they're
thinking about going down sacrifice the
first couple of years three four years
of your career
to be in a good system and then you get
your money later on you know because
you'll have a
you'll get that four years back easily
get to the store with Pat Duff in your
career is going to absolutely take off
yeah this was a good recruitment
I'll see how I go and then what was it
like when you got to the storm like like
you said just just out of school a long
way to travel
um where were you living how was your
day-to-day life yeah it was a rude shock
when I first got there I got the thing I
got there on like the end of November
they got there on like a Friday we were
doing Hills on the Friday with under 20s
team
and like I turned out and I would think
we did we did weights testing in the
morning on the Friday morning and I was
putrid like
absolutely putrid like I think I I was I
was warming up with Jordan McLean so he
turned up the same day Jordan McLean's
like the front row from the Cowboys and
then
um
a guy oh I forget his last name I was
first name but it's Lomax so it was like
one of the Lomax boys and a lot of Lomax
boys is they're like Monsters you know
like I'm sure it would have been related
to Tire elements anyway they'll warming
up and they're like oh bench press all
right or just do the bar to warm up that
I'm like and had barely done weights
before
so I did the bar and then
um and then they go we'll Chuck 60 on
there and I said yeah no worries so I
didn't want to say anything I did 60 and
I was like man that was heavy like it
was crazy and that would just like pump
out like 15 reps anyway they Chuck on I
said oh maybe just try for like 80.
don't even know how to even like I think
I put 10 on one side and then two fives
on the other you know you're a complete
rookie when you're doing that and so
then I've just come down and I've I've
dropped it and and I had no chest
longest arms ever looked like a praying
mantis and I've just dropped it straight
on my chest and then it's just got stuck
and I'm like oh just like absolutely
battling you know so I failed went after
the training and said oh I got um I got
a 80 and he goes you didn't get 80 you
got 60 and I was like oh okay sweet I
got 60. so it was my 60 kilo 1rm bench
press and then I went over to the squat
rack and we did squats in the same thing
60 and then went to 90 and I just got
one rep at 90 and then I wrapped it up
and I'm like I'm like my knees were
wobbling and stuff and I think the chin
up I literally did body weight so
anyway that was a Friday morning and
then and then I'm just feeling like a
ship like the whole day got to the
Friday afternoon and we're out on the
hills and I'm like right like I was
skinny uh this is I'm gonna rip in and
like and luckily enough I I like I went
good on the Hills like because I was I
think at the time I was like 87 kilos
yeah and all I've been doing is running
I was
um playing afl-40 back in Auckland and
it was during their preseason yeah so I
was just running like running long
distances and so yeah I smoked it up the
hills and then from that point the snc
guy I was so lucky like he was he hated
fat guys he didn't mind the week guys
they could run but he hated the fat guys
so he never rode me at all the preseason
because I was just like you know I don't
know if I was winning all the runs but
yeah I would have been up there top
three or whatever so that was day one I
mean but yeah the preseason that time
was it was tough man like
we would train the same like do the same
sessions as the NRL side but would have
to do it either in the morning or in
that evening so we'll get us getting up
at like 5 15.
catching the train
um to princess Park would do weights in
the morning and we'll be finished by say
seven and then would be off to work and
at that point we'll just do laboring
because like so we're laboring all day
during the like Melbourne summer
go back in the afternoon do like skills
commissioning in the afternoon get home
at like 7 P.M 8 P.M cook dinner boom
fall asleep back to square one the next
day like it's it was relentless
Relentless so but I mean to be honest at
the time I was just like
it just also Yahoo is this is not the
hell is this like if that if I was doing
that nowadays right the head noise would
be ridiculous
you're ridiculous though
yeah so that was pretty much full full
on until
yeah we started playing trials in
February so
um but yeah ended up having a good
season that year we went through won the
comp
um with our team we had like a really
good team in 2009 we won the comp 20s
and then NRA one at the same day
so we had a strong club and then sort of
towards the back end of that year
um I don't I don't know if it was after
the season or the back end of the year
but there was about 10 or 11 of us that
got
um put up into first grade so like we
got contracts so my second year in my
20s contract just got changed to a
two-year NRL contract all right and so
that was good like 11 of us went up and
um yeah started the pre-season for 2010
in November which was yeah which was
cool 11's a big number eh that's um it's
a good recruitment tool for like you say
this time yeah I think we've always had
like a big turnover because well
particularly during those days those
days because we had
well we had the big four at that point
we had GI Billy Cooper cam yeah but then
obviously that came came out the next
year with the salary cap stuff like but
even though technically over the salary
cap or whatever but they were still big
turnover because all the guys on the
fringes
like obviously us 11 came up we were all
on minimum minimum wage so then you
stacker team would be like we were just
role players you know what I mean and
that's kind of how it was back then you
have the big three or big four everyone
else in there you just sort of Battlers
not not everyone but everyone's sort of
you're just role-playing to create a
system for these three guys so
so that's kind of how it how it was back
then but um but I mean like we weren't
complaining we're loving it it was it
was awesome yeah and what were the big
four like obviously for Legends of the
game all all in one team that you're in
and what was it like working with them
were they welcoming yeah oh amazing
amazing just the way they operated I
probably didn't appreciate it at the
time but you know I the 2010 season that
was my first season and we literally had
Greg English Cooper crop Camp Smith
Billy Slater and our team
but then you look at the rest of the
team weird like you know Edibles Kirby
Proctor
um Brett White was in the front row like
with Ryan hitchcliffe yeah we had
honestly a stack team and so it was
awesome though like I probably I
probably worked with Billy the most
through my career or his career in my
career just because him playing fullback
I'm playing Wing he kind of took me
under his wing a little bit
um and again a lot of his stuff was
around habits you know like
um off the ball work and stuff that
would make his job easier easier he was
he was real hard on me and in that way
so just around covering the backfield
with our pendulum and stuff like that
like if he goes left I've got to cover
that space he's leaving and stuff like
that so he taught me a lot um you know
hard on me at times but off a field
great and just the way they would get up
for big games was pretty crazy like you
know they could just
yeah like when it came to finals time
they just had different different looks
in their eyes you know they were just
like they're honestly like sharks it was
crazy and it would nearly just be like
boys get out of the road you know get
out of the road because these boys are
going to dominate right
yeah they drive most of the wind
um yeah yeah I think so yeah like Craig
was Craig would always be like an eagle
looking over training and stuff but cam
was pretty much
Cameron Cooper sort of drove the team
around and Billy was kind of the Tassie
devil like just like buzzing around the
joint because he's got so much energy on
the field
um and sort of Cam and Cooper would just
be sort of keeping everyone moving in
the same direction you know so but yeah
there's some of the stuff that they'll
do at training though like particularly
Billy like some of the things he would
do at training was just like you know
out of this world like it was especially
being a wiener like he's throwing he's
getting pressure from it he's just like
not even looking through and like sort
of 15 20 meter passes
and just headed me straight on the chest
yeah you know and so and the big thing
for him was like he if say if he would
throw a pass and if I'd be too deep or
too flat or whatever and I wouldn't I
wasn't catching it it was like it'd be
like my fault it would be the past
because he would always just throw it to
the space and like not looking yeah and
so that's sort of some of the things
that I've been trying to
say to the wing is this year like
because I've been at the NRL training so
it's like it's actually on you to get
the ball you know it's like you got to
be in the right the same place every
time so that the fullbacks know you know
they don't have to look they can just
throw it so yeah that was that was a big
thing for me is that he'd often say
sort of oh yeah you want the ball make
sure you're in the right place
make sure I can see you make sure you
know you're in the right right place
because I'll throw it there you've just
gotta it's on you to be there not on me
to find you you know right I like that
as well that's good and you became a
pretty good Target for the Cronk as well
didn't you like
um he'd often look look for you for the
um fifth tackle play Get Up nice and
nice and high in the air
um often came down with the with the
ball yeah yeah that was obviously I
think you know looking back on my career
I think it's the sort of aerial stuff is
probably there's definitely something
that allowed me to have a long career it
was even if I wasn't this here breaking
tackles or you know setting up tries or
stuff I was always a Target
for us attack wise but also defensively
is safe so that's something that I was
really passionate about and yeah cooper
cooper would look for me
um but I I didn't notice that if I if I
didn't get the first one I'd often not
get any for the rest of the game so I
remember I always remember going to
games I'd be like make sure the first
one I need to go and go like go and get
it like I need to make sure I get it
like I was always so much pressure on
the first Crossfield kick because it
always he'd literally one chance and
then if they did start grabbering for
other people or
um stuff like that so
um but yeah it was I enjoyed that part I
it was something that even in 20s like
we had a good
awesome half back in 20 there's a great
Kirk Luke Kelly
and um yeah we scored a bunch of drives
that year just from just from that exact
thing just no doubt because I I was
doing the AFL training back in Auckland
so there's a lot of a lot of yeah it
just kind of that that stuff kind of
came kind of came naturally to me yeah
and you did score a lot of tries in your
first year one try in particular that I
did want to talk about was the one where
you
famously knock yourself out doing a it
was a face plant as you score one of the
great tries yeah yeah yeah that one at
Canberra I would have been I would have
been hia bloody probably probably missed
next week if I did that nowadays
um but yeah it was a it was just one of
those I don't know I actually I still
remember like everything up into that
like even playing in the ball I still
remember everything like yeah about it
and obviously I've watched it back and
stuff but yeah there was a play with me
um Cooper went
through like a a flat cut out ball to
keep your Proctor I think and then he
caught it at the line and gave like a
return ball to Billy ripped it back to
Billy and then we just had like a a
short long shape on the edge and I knew
straight and like I was just like
pinning it for the corner because I knew
he was going to throw it out in front
and then I just got like a push and I
was like off balance but I used it like
I just got to get the ball down but I
had my head facing right
so when I hit the ground like I didn't I
couldn't roll over but if I had my head
sort of facing left I would have just
rolled over my shoulder so then I ended
up facing right and then I remembered
after the game or that week after the
game I had this big scab behind my ear
because I'd Sledge like with my ear
forward like that so it's like so
there's a big like scab behind my ear
and um but yeah we're back to halfway
and pretty much just I just you just
keep playing back then like it was just
yeah it's amazing like I think about it
now and I'm just like man that's just
like wouldn't it's just like not even a
thing now like uh for the better as well
like for the better like I was pretty
crook you know yeah
but it's just it yeah did you have any
memory loss or anything that any
symptoms straight away that you knew
like if you knew now you'd be like Jesus
I'm off now I'll just I remember just
sort of when the ball got kicked off
again just being like man this is weird
like a I was like this feels like deja
vu you know when you get that color yeah
yeah yeah you kind of like you're kind
of like oh I'm here oh like I like I
knew where I was and everything like I
was fine no headaches and stuff and yeah
like I kind of knew what had happened
but I was kind of like oh this is a
weird feeling like yeah so Deja Vu is a
weird one I always thought it was sort
of just me who got those but does
everyone get those Deja Vu moments where
you feel like you've been in before
after a head knock yeah it's weirdo yeah
I don't know what it is I I um yeah I
although I need it I got a bone to pick
with your family actually hey your your
brother over in uh over in Japan he gave
me more than Deja Vu I was Bloody out
cold and we played it was a preseason
game did he wasn't a cheap shot was it
well I oh if it was a real game he would
have got red I reckon because it's a
head Clash not looking after the player
with the ball oh true but I've caught in
past and then I just remember waking up
walking off the field and I'm but I'm
already saying nah I'm sweet I'm sweet
I'm sweet you know but and then I
watched replay back and I was like yeah
cold on the ground
um they got me a beauty oh he's a grub
no he is a grub man it's not good enough
but you have had a few um serious
injuries throughout your career
um was a couple of shoulders ACL all
look pretty niggly times as you're
trying to sort of progress your career
how are they to deal with
yeah it was it was pretty tough tough
time I think um
I don't know the post you put up
actually about the questions there's
there's a photo in that posted me and
Cooper and that that is that was the
round four game
2013 which was actually my last game of
inner hour before I had a bunch of
injuries like I that's when I went out
when I was gone for like two and a half
years so yeah it was the first couple
were not too bad because it was end of
season stuff so 2010 into season 2011 in
the season 2012 in the season they're
all shoulder shoulder surgeries
but then that 2011 or 2013 sorry
um that's when so that game that was the
only time I'd ever been dropped
um in my career at storm so they get the
Broncos game
and I've actually scored two tries that
game but I was just I was putrid and
defense but it was it was a combination
of my confidence levels not having
pre-season from the
from The Surge off season surgeries I
wasn't having pre-seasons and then I was
just getting down down in confidence
down in confidence anyway I um got
dropped went back to reserve grade
popped my shoulder out because I was
just trying to flog everyone and I had
I've got praying mantis arms as you know
pop my shoulder out and then uh a real
bad headspace you know not dealing with
it well and then but you know just
telling everyone Vietnam Suite I'm just
gonna work my way but work hard work
hard work hard yeah came back six weeks
later after popping my shoulder out and
then I did my ACL
so I had my I had to have my right
shoulder done and my left ACL done so I
think I
got my ACL done and then once I was off
crutches I got my shoulder done so I was
walking around with a knee brace on the
left and then and then a right shoulder
oh yeah so that was I think that point I
was like I still kind of like man this
is bad you know but I thought all right
I'll give it one more crack I stood a
year on my on my contract so I was like
I'll give 24 to any crack but you know
if I do my ACL again I'm just going to
retire like I was in such a dark Deep
head space anyway changed a bunch of
stuff in my life like you know just
really zeroed in on what I wanted to do
and was working with someone external
you know cleaned all my diet up wasn't
really you know giving on the drink too
much and stuff and then rehabbed was
feeling really good like probably the
best I'd best condition I'd been in like
my knee was still you know still getting
there and then I think nine months after
that I played a game in the preseason
then I played the tens tournament
and then after the tennis tournament I
sat training the week after going to the
third trial game and then I did my ACL
again so I did my last list ACL and that
was in 2014 and it was like and at that
point I was kind of like I can't believe
it like I've done all these things like
kind of in this mindset like I deserve
to I deserve to play like and all this
stuff like I had this really sort of
like poor me
you know all this stuff and anyway
I didn't have a contract for 2015
um but the club so I remember Craig
saying to me like oh don't make a
decision now on what you're going to do
because you have to get the surgery
anyway to get the surgery rehab it for
this year
be around the club and do what you can
and then make a decision at the end of
the year what you're going to do so
I did that I I changed everything up I
saw three different surgeons
um again changed keep going with the
same lifestyle like really cleaned
everything up but kind of went into it
with like a if I can just get back on
the field
that that is like the ultimate goal like
I didn't matter if I was playing Club
rugby Queensland car like whereas the
year before I was thinking like I'm
going to come back into the NRL you know
show everyone all the haters that I was
all around like it was a bit it was like
a
bit of an ego trip you know so I just
stripped it right back changed the bunch
and and then just really
zeroed in just change up my training
environment you know just tried to
really yeah
um change everything up and so I just
keep working away and then end of 2014
the club actually said I will give you
uh one more year contract because they
could obviously see that I was I hadn't
literally hadn't played for two and a
half years and they said I'll give you
another year contract it was obviously a
minimum wage and heavily you know match
payments and stuff like that so it was
all really on me but they could see all
the stuff I was doing off field and
working with the doing a lot of
leadership stuff so
we're back in
um ended up coming back round four and
2015 in Queensland cup and like played
horrific like uh literally someone would
grab my jersey and I was so terrified of
being out there I was just crumbling to
the ground like just dropping just
dropping straight to my knees because I
didn't want anyone around me just didn't
want anyone near my knee but then that
year I just progressed each week or just
get sort of stuck getting better and
better and better and then I was
fortunate enough that year
2015 and like around 20
um Craig Craig sort of just said to me
like um yeah we're going to give you a
crack I remember I was driving to the
airport because we played Queensland cup
so I was driving out to the airport to
get on the flight to go to Queensland
and then one of the assistant coaches
called me and he goes hey mate um oh
you're not going up to Queensland this
week and we had a buy for storm and then
so it was like around 9 10 and then I
was like oh he's like I just just don't
go to the airport we've canceled your
flight you just go back home and and
we've got a
we've got like a dress-up party tonight
so just come to the dress-up party
um and just stay in Melbourne for the
weekend I was like oh beautiful like
awesome
and it's straight away I'm thinking like
[ __ ] look at the crackhead I'm gonna
crack that I don't want me to get rest
like risk it up in Queensland cup anyway
the week after then yeah he pulled me
aside like on the Monday and he was like
oh I'm gonna give you I'm going to give
you a go this weekend yeah I've seen you
like you know going to ride and you know
the guy that was playing on the wing at
the time he was he he was sort of young
and it it wasn't he was going right and
I kind of felt bad because he's actually
going all right but
I think he just wanted to give me a
crack so he'll played around 20 over in
Napier actually against the dragons
um there was a we took a game over there
sure and uh yeah made my return it was
like 850 days or so after after that
that Broncos game in round four
um 2013 so and yeah and ended up playing
the rest of the season so yeah I learned
a lot about myself during that time like
I I think um you know looking back now
and even at the time I remember at the
time like I never wished it didn't
happen to me because
I probably wouldn't be sitting here
right now if it didn't happen to me you
know what I mean like as weird as that
is to say all the things that I've
learned through going through those hard
times has is actually helping with my
life you know it actually helps
everything I've got nothing seems too
hard or too far-fetched or whatever now
because I know that at that point we're
like what I kind of got over and
push through like it's it gives you a
lot of confidence to get through those
hard times so
um I'm fortunate that I got out the
other side I don't know if you know if I
had got another knee injury I was like
oh I don't know but um
yeah did you get close to call and quits
on the on the game or was that never
really the option it was always about
getting back oh different definitely got
close definitely got clothes like there
was a point there where you know it was
pretty pretty bare like when I did the
two injuries in a row like I'm on
painkillers for my knee
and then because I got surgery on my
shoulder three weeks later like I
literally went painkillers on my knee
and then I went straight into
painkillers for my
right shoulder
and I remember I went back to New
Zealand after I'd recovered
pretty well like mostly from both of
them and um I was waking up in the
middle of the night and I just had like
I was just drenching like cold sweats
and I'm like man what's going on like
I'm not sick I'm like oh this is so
weird
and I realized like a couple nights
after it started like I was literally
coming down off like pain because it's
got literally been on painkillers for
like four weeks straight you know what I
mean and I didn't even realize it at the
time but and and I was like
I wasn't healthy like it was pale you
know I'd just been through two major
surgeries it was just like it was pretty
bad like you know what you go through
and then you get to that point and you
come and go yeah but then
as Craig said it's just like well no
point of making the decision now might
as well wait till the end of the year
I'm still getting paid until October
31st of
the year after there's no point in
making a decision just rip into your
rehab until October 31st or October then
make a decision then you you need to
rehab for life you know I need to rehab
my knee because I don't want to limp
around for the rest of my life so you
might as well just
don't make a decision when you're overly
emotional and stuff like that so there
was a lot of times where I'm like ah man
bugger this I'd love to throw it in and
but then
unfortunately I didn't really to be
honest I still don't know what I want to
do when I grow up so I didn't really
know at that point what I want to do so
yeah it's all up you know so a lot of
guys work at work away at something
off-field and stuff but I never really
did that ass really just invested in
fully I tried things here and there but
I never really sort of you know so yeah
so you get back for the storm you're
back playing first grade and then why
the switch to Union yeah well so they've
2015 season towards the end of the
season like I didn't really have
anything going and I was just pushing
everything to the side like if I'd get
an inquiry I just said to a manager like
I just want to play footy play finals
with the storm and stuff but I actually
ended up having a few offers but I think
it was more the fact that I was going
cheap because of all my injuries so a
lot of clubs discount trying to you know
a bit of experience
um it wasn't like I was getting it
wasn't like it was a bidding war it was
more
we could maybe Jag this fellow and he
might be a good backup or whatever but
and then obviously so we had I had three
clubs in our clubs and then either Blues
and sort of I'd always had this itching
feeling that I wanted to go back to
Union it probably had been delayed a bit
because of my injuries but I was Keen
like I think the timing of everything
was just really good you know like
tunnel was starting at the blues
um it was my hometown although I didn't
want a permission but the storm I feel
like
getting back from injury was like one of
the biggest things and well it's still
probably my career highlight playing
that round 20 game so
I feel like at the time I was like man
it'd be great to be in a different
environment where I don't have that
history behind me you know I can just go
Forge another path and
you know every time I get a niggling
injury here like all the fans would be
like oh injured again you know or like
they don't know they're doing it but
you know office you know people in the
office and stuff would be like oh are
you injured again you know and it's bit
and I was just like oh man can you break
the shackle of of like these of my
history so it was just like a few things
lined up and I just had a decision to
make like I could
stay stay at store but I I just I just
thought
if I'm going to give it a crack it's
going to be now when I'm 25 rather than
when I was 27 so I I could have taken
the two-year contract in the NRL
tried to make the switch at 27. but then
you never know and then
and like kind of when you start to slow
down and rugby league you'll really the
only option is over in the UK north of
England and I never really imagined
myself looking over there I just kind of
they're going to the Super league and
then I knew like if I go and give Unity
crack and it goes good I could go to
France Japan you know I could go to
England you know there's so many more
options so I was like well it's now or
never gotta have a crack I um yeah
obviously a big fan of tunnel I never
met I met him once actually and I knew
his son his son came over to the storm
so oh yeah I was Keen to work under him
and then
um yeah so
have a crack see what happens and then
so I got a two-year contract and and I
was playing at Harbor which was cool
um but the only the one thing was that
that was difficult I went straight into
Super Rugby uh it would have been nice
to go domestic rugby Super Rugby but
just the way the seasons work out I
couldn't do a domestic season so
um and obviously as you would have seen
it was a hell of an intro it's a it's a
Super Rugby my first game when
um the money sent me to send me to the
Moon
was that your first game of Super Rugby
now that question came in more than any
other question
um I can imagine for you obviously and
there's everyone remember
that was it was that your first game of
rugby you've got big namani nadolo one
of the hottest men in the game to tackle
so what a nice reaction right so 2016
right like so we have we all like our
squad has a great preseason like we win
all our preseason games and we come out
round and then they picked the team for
round one and Oscar and I was going to
write like I played a ride in the
preseason and stuff and then they came
to round one at a time and just goes
we're gonna go with experiences back at
Eden Park you know it's a really really
big game it's like we're gonna go with
experience so a lot playing fullback
which is fine like I was just like oh
you know that's cool like I'll buy my
time or whatever so we win round one
against the Holland there's a huge win
we're like everyone's behind us or like
the blues are back
anyway round two rolls around and he's
and like Tana's gone oh all right we're
gonna start your fullback this week yeah
and then they changed the team and then
they changed like the whole team that
week and we'll play Crusaders at
Christchurch
and I'm like thinking
oh is it like even I'm thinking like is
that the right decision you know what I
mean like
we might be able to build some
continuity like like road trip to
crushed it for my first game starting
fullback I have like
and really when I think about it now I
had no idea how to play rugby union like
no idea it was like crazy but anyway
that's that's fine what what I what I
used to once I got over the trauma of
being
um on every highlight reel for that week
or that month or year or whatever
I used to say to the boys
mate I made the uh I made the Super
Rugby ad in my first game and like I
don't know how many boys have made their
first game made the Super Rugby act
because I was just like they normally
make those ads like well in advance and
I literally got put straight in like it
was like the next week they were running
these super ugly hands and I'm like
getting punched like a
yeah so promoting the game yeah I
remember talking to the money after the
game
and uh in the sheds and then he goes oh
when I was running towards you I thought
I thought you were gonna hit me because
you come from league and I'm like are
you serious mate have you said one have
you seen the size of you and have you
seen me play rugby league I couldn't
tackle it I couldn't tackle anyone
but I think he was just trying to make
me feel good no yeah but I ended up
later later that year I got well after
the game
after that game I got dropped back to I
was playing Club rugby mate the whole
year and it was funny like my wife's
from Melbourne and she won't mind me
telling this because lucky we laugh
about it now
but like I signed a two-year contract
and then after the I played one game
round two and then I was pretty much
playing for Club rugby for like a lot of
the year that year yeah and uh she
didn't say to me at the time but I think
it was after like after the year like
after it made the all black she goes ah
I was thinking after your first year
you know is this really how you imagine
the switch that Rugby Union when you're
like Saturday afternoon two o'clock
playing with like some bloke like some
trading with a knee knee wrap on like
like just there to spend it after the
games like drinking beers and stuff so
yeah it's pretty it's funny I can look
back and now and laugh like but I ended
up
towards the end of that season I I went
to um I got picked again the next
Crusaders game at Eden Park but this
time so the first game I was playing
fullback so I wasn't necessarily marking
the dollar yeah the next game I played
right wing he played left wing I was
literally marking him and I remember I
remember when they named the team they
tana and me and Tyler had to sit down
and hit a yard and he goes oh
he's like this weekend he's just like
just be really sure about where you're
gonna tackle him this weekend so if
you're going high
start low and then surprise that we'd go
high he's like if you're going if you're
going low start high and the surprise
would go low and he was like
like honestly I went into the game I
made
my extras that week I was literally just
getting like the biggest guys and just
tackling around the legs but I ended up
I ended up making a few tackles but like
I actually played really well that
second game against them it was actually
like really really fun like really fun
like I cut them down to a few tackles
and yeah it was good so mate that's so
funny so how how hard is that transition
obviously it happens a fair bit
interesting to hear how you felt going
into your debut like feeling like you
had sort of no idea what you're doing
how hard is that transition especially
in that back three yeah oh crazy like
before I came up like I was pretty
motivated when I made the switch like I
was I was really Keen to sort of make an
impact and like I could see opportunity
for me at the blues and stuff like
playing fullback and sort of what what I
learned at the storm and stuff like that
but I remember the first training
session I was like I was running around
like a league fullback I was just trying
to follow the ball everywhere like I was
I was running from like left to right to
left to right and I wasn't touching the
ball at all like literally trying to get
out of the back of a block play like
every single play the ball's so fast I
ended up I was like random side to side
and my GPS numbers were through the roof
like I remember like and I was barely
touching the ball because I was just
running around like an idiot but
um it takes a while and I think once I
after that point I pretty much
transitioned onto the wing
so for the next year and a half I pretty
much played Wing played a little bit of
fullback at Harbor but um yeah I was
mostly playing on the win game and it
was a lot more simplified the role and
and probably
I probably work towards my attributes
more than at that point was worked
towards like my
like what I was good at it was a lot of
it was around the high balls
um like chasing kicks catching kicks and
stuff whereas that fall back you're more
you know you've got to be tactically
really good and kick well and
um link like outside backs and you know
you're going to be like a link man but
you also got to be dangerous and make
good decisions and stuff so whereas on
the wing you you like be a good finisher
roam around when you can
you know create opportunity save under
the high ball and stuff so I was way way
more suited to me and I think going into
that it just allowed me to play play
like play regular games get my
confidence up start to figure out on the
run like where I can insert myself and
stuff like that so but it took a while
like it was literally
a full Super Rugby pre-season plus
season plus uh domestic pre-season
domestic season probably the Super Rugby
preseason even the start of that year I
probably wasn't playing that well but
Tyler kept backing me at right when yeah
and then it was probably
it was actually the my return game back
to the Crusaders
down in Christchurch and that's where
everything clicked for me that 2017
season like I uh my first half
I made like a couple of line breaks and
I was just feeling like I just felt like
way that's way better around
what I was seeing I felt like really
dangerous and but I changed a bunch of
stuff during that preseason as well like
I think when I first got over I was I
probably didn't earn it enough like I
didn't earn it through hard work where I
felt like also maybe a little bit
entitled when I came over like I felt
like I was a little bit
oh you know I can come from the storm
like we're world class and and I knew I
was really motivated but I was probably
motivated in the wrong areas whereas
2017 season I I can stripped it right
back and I was just like I'm just going
to work my ass off at the gym get
physically strong like work real hard on
the training field
um
and then yeah and then once I get into
the season just see what happens to have
like a really really solid routine so I
was getting into the club like first I
was first at the club like every morning
I'd get up at I think I was getting up
at like 5 30 and literally just get in
my car get to the club by six and I'll
do like a big rehab session before
that's where we're like 45 minutes in
the gym and then I'll go have brekkie
then then the day would start you know
and I just sort of I was doing all that
stuff by myself and I and it was like
something something was just clicking
for me like I I think doing a lot of
that hard work with no one's watching
and when it's cold and it's dark and
it's hard like stuff just starts to
happen for you you know the the harder
you work the luckier you get and so oh
yeah there was I think it was I think it
was maybe round three
um 2017 and then it just went something
clicked on the field and then
yeah pretty much win their whole season
2017 and like playing really good footy
like every week I was
like getting better and being played
like good footy and I felt real
confident and stuff like that so that
was a really really enjoyable I'd say
2017 was by far my best year of my
career for sure like in terms of and I
was us 26 10 to 27 that year so I felt
like I was in physical Pride like
everything like that yeah and you kept
it off with uh making your all Black
debut so you obviously knew you're
playing well but did you know you're
playing well enough to have the
attention of the all black selectors and
how'd you find out yeah well
it's really hard to once you get in
there you get in that rumor mill you
know because it wasn't
because like these things always start
to snowball you know like Jordy Barrett
got injured in South Africa that year
and Ben Smith was on a sabbatical and
then and then I think
uh Izzy dag was
injured yeah or sabbatical and so
they're not the harbor boys at the time
when it's really started rare Purpose
with Ed Harbor because I was playing at
Harvard right it was just Relentless
like the boys are just like oh you're
gonna make it you're gonna make it and
I'm just like I just didn't want to hear
it because it's just you know and to be
honest I was like playing good footy at
Harvard that year as well and I was like
after a game and stuff like it'd be
Juno's asking me reporters ask me or
like radio oh how do you reckon and I'm
just like I didn't want to hear it
didn't want to hear it anyway got to the
Daily naming and I remember waking up
and I woke up at like seven o'clock and
and I think the Navy was at midday or
something and I'm just like I said to my
missus I said
I just can't sit in the house because
this is going to be the longest morning
of my life we have to do something we
have to go out and I just gotta get out
of the house because I was just like
couldn't sleep that night before even
though in my head I was like I'm not
gonna make a knuckle make it I just
couldn't sleep and I couldn't sit still
anyway so we went out and then we got
back and I think it was maybe 10 30 the
announcement and then it was on Facebook
live I think so we logged on on the
laptop and we're like oh I was like oh
do I watch it or do I not watch it like
if I watch it and I don't get named it's
like you know I'll be disappointed but
anyway like Chuck it up on Facebook live
and
sitting in my uh kitchen with with my
partner and yeah and then they went
through and it like it was alphabetical
because my name my last name starts with
d and I was probably like the third or
fourth
um name and then it was just like it was
crazy uh crazy crazy morning like I just
couldn't believe it like
hearing your name read out in that
scenario and then my phone just lit up
like it was insane they were like within
argue within five minutes it would have
been like 200 text messages on my phone
just from the randomest people to like
this random random people anyway
remember this is sort of for last for
for about an hour we were just just
gobsmacked like crazy got a call from
Steve Hanson
um about 10 minutes after he just said
oh like you know welcome and you're
looking forward to having here and and
explain why I'd been picked and stuff
and oh I don't even know if he explained
why I've been picked but he
um
just say it all we'll see you Friday and
I think it was like the Monday so pretty
much
um yeah get my stuff sorted and we'll
see on Friday at the airport
and uh yeah they'd end up I ended up
jumping TV3 or TV one or something
wanted to do an interview about it at
North Harbor stadium so I jumped and my
car went out to North Harbor stadium and
uh did the interview anyway at that
point I didn't realize this is until
like three days later but my dad was
sitting at home when it happened and he
was the same as me he was just like
didn't know what to do with himself so
he just jumped in his car didn't even
call me anything and he just came over
to my house
and but it's like it's like an hour's
drive so he's like driven over and I'm
not home because I'm out at North Harbor
stadium and he told me like three days
over he's like I actually couldn't he's
like I couldn't sit in my house anymore
like he's just like I had to come see
you and then so he's knocking on my door
and I'm not even home and so he's just
sit he's just sat around for like half
an hour and I still come back so he just
went back home and he's like drove her
now back out
yeah it was like amazing time for like
my family and whenever I'm sort of my
friends and stuff and everyone that sort
of been a part of
you know those really hard times you
know I sort of through that week I
really like reflected on man I was
nearly about to give the game away and
man last year I was literally playing
for takapuna right I I do my domain on a
two o'clock on a Saturday yeah getting
sprayed by all the old old folks on the
sideline like
and then fast forward sort of 12 18
months but
um but it was exciting and then yeah I
we were my wife were getting married in
December and I also wait for all of
November so I was like oh well good luck
I guess you're gonna have to uh organize
the rest of the week that's crazy well
to be honest I was supposed to go on my
stag do at the end of November to
Rarotonga so I had more my groomsmen
then my brother and my little brother
and stuff and not playing the strip and
so the boys are like oh we're still
gonna go so I was literally over and I
said whales I think and now we're in
Rarotonga and they had like this big
cardboard cutout of me and they were
partying it up and Rarotonga
but then I think I'm pretty sure my my
credit card was on the on the room and
and they'd like put a hole in the wall
and I'm like oh
yeah
right that's crazy I love stories like
that that's one of the coolest things
about the game how quickly it can all
change either one way or the other a one
minute you can be a hero next minute
zero or vice versa like like you say
plank a Brad Pitt takapuna and then a
year later you're playing the All Blacks
and running out with the silver Fern on
your chest uh what was that experience
like doing the Haka yeah yeah I made
sure I had myself up the back behind one
of the big front rowers I wasn't
intimidating anyone but I was also like
I think that that first uh game against
the bar bars in London us uh coming off
the bench so
um yeah just being up there singing the
National Anthem in front of like
60 or 50 60 000 people in London I was
it was it was just bizarre even from
from the point where I went into the
camp it was just bizarre like the whole
month was just crazy like I was just the
whole environment what it comes with
like being a part of that and what
happens when you when you get in there
and then yeah just just an amazing
amazing environment to be a part of
um I was just soaking it and loving it
um making the most of it you know like
just
going on every day off trip with anyone
and just playing cards with everyone and
just just yeah barely spent a moment in
my room you know like this yeah soaked
it all in and but yeah
definitely singing the National Anthem
was a huge uh emotional sort of thing to
happen and I played The Barbers game
came off the bench for like 10 minutes
didn't didn't touch the ball didn't make
a tackle but it was like the best 10
minutes of my life and then we played
the French Barbers and I I started that
game on the right wing and played 80
minutes so that was cool because uh
event team we had like it was like
Richard Wonga played Nani
um and this was all back when I was sort
of conversing onto the scene or like
they'd played a sort of in and out uh
Jack good who played
I think theater played left wing I
played right-wing David harvilly at 15 I
think tower started at nine and then we
had yeah so we had like a sort of a
young team with a few experienced guys
and
um playing against uh uh French bar bars
who
literally more experienced than the
actual French team that played the week
before it was like they they'd try to
get one of the scalps so they they ended
up chucking heaps of the gun players but
my first involvement
they threw the ball over to the hooker
was standing on the wagon the wing and
he was just like a ball of muscle
and he's running and I'm like I'm gonna
all black like in my head I'm like I'm
in an all blacks Jersey I'm not missing
this tackle and I just went in like just
shut my eyes and he just like he just
bumped me off ran straight over top of
me and like nearly scored and the boy's
like oh remember the time just running
back just in that complete
um Panic like oh my God I can't believe
I missed the tackle in the All Blacks
Jersey like I was just sprinting back
and I like literally hit like every Rock
after that you know when you're just
panicking and just like yeah I was just
diving my head into every Rock just
trying to like stop a try that one meter
from my line ended up but then after
that after that I had a few couple of
good touches and um came good but it was
it was fun like I was just again just
trying to lap it up like I was
um towards the end of the game we
started giving yellow cards like just
for like real pity stuff like the French
ref and the crowd was just going berserk
and I started it directly with the crowd
like just said like a fun way and that
were great and um
but yeah it was just it was a cool
experience and my dad was there with his
partner so and I saw him after the game
and he's just like a absolute mess like
he's just like balling his eyes out yeah
pretty cool
so cool so yeah I know you mentioned
that backline a lot of those guys are
you know still regular all backs now
what area can stop you from becoming
that sort of regular all black or
getting more tests than you did yeah I
don't know I've reflected on it a little
bit like I think 2018 was a frustrating
year and I think it probably is
um can be that second year
can be frustrating for a lot of players
um I ended up playing a lot of fullback
at at Blues in 2018 like at the start of
the year and it wasn't yeah I don't know
it was just I wasn't our team wasn't
playing well I wasn't really playing
well I was putting a lot of effort into
the things I talked about before around
getting up early and doing all that
stuff but
maybe on reflection I maybe wasn't
fully fully invested in it like I was
doing it but maybe I was just taking a
box and yeah I'll never know like it's
easier to climb the mountain than it is
to stay at the top you know and because
you got guys looking at the heels and
especially in New Zealand being an
outside back you know you there's always
an outside back every single year that
pops on the scene and is a gun you know
so yeah and again the the guys I
mentioned before like Ben Smith Jordy
Barrett is he dag they weren't involved
that year so then you put them back in
and then
there'll be another guy pop out the
ground in 2018 I don't know exactly who
it was but
but yeah I I did I played a lot of fall
back the year which was enjoyable but
then towards the end I think I had I had
my first daughter in September playing
and I was playing for North Harbor and
um
a week later I tore my hamstring off the
bone oh sure which was yeah which is a
major that was like that was my only
major surgery
and rugby unit
um so yeah it was pretty that kind of
that really sort of affected obviously
affected the NWS stuff but I probably
wasn't playing it playing that well
anyway so so then the move to Japan so
why did why'd you go to Japan in the end
yeah so 2019 I resigned with the blues
for one year or no so I had 19.
I struggled a bit of 19 my hamstring
just wasn't
it just took way longer than I thought
and I probably never got back to what I
was before like after that
but I'm not I'm not saying I didn't get
I couldn't get back to performing well I
just wasn't the same after I tore my
Army off the bone yeah like there's a
big surgery and a lot of guys have been
retired through that so no 19 was a bit
of a battle
um even at Harbor like the harbor was
normally like my safe area like it was
like some environment I really loved and
even the 19 season at Harbor was a
struggle like
um
we've got a new coach and just sort of I
wasn't in a great like headspace and you
know it was just like a bit of a bit of
a blowout of a year to be honest and but
like home life was great like I had this
new daughter and she was growing up and
stuff so I was just like a bit of a
yeah just footy was a bit of a struggle
like Leon Leon came up in 2019 and I
wasn't I've been starting for three
years and then I was coming back from
injury and I was battling just even to
make the team so and I wasn't playing
good so anyway
uh 2020 World round had a good preseason
like a really good preseason then I
ended up starting round one
um at fullback for the blues and us I
was I feel like I just got over like I
was physically asked back to I reckon I
was back but then um
started at fullback and then I wasn't
let's start again didn't play that well
but I stayed in the team for a bit and
then
um kind of got to mid-year and then I
started coming off the bench
and yeah like I just wasn't playing that
well and and I probably sat back and I
was like kind of ready to go then like
I'd done
I kind of knew maybe that I pretty much
knew that I was never going to get back
into that all blacks environment and
maybe it was time for me to go as bad as
it sounds go cash it and uh go
experience something new
uh we've been in Auckland for five years
and the plan is always was always to
come back to Melbourne so
I just thought
go over to Japan have a crack but this
was all during covert so like rugby had
pretty much like come to a halt
um and I'm like sitting at home and
we're sitting at home like just like
praying that we get a Japanese contract
whenever all the Japan clubs are just
like oh we're not signing you I'm not
signing it and so fortunate enough to
get a contract and by that time we're
having our second baby at the end of
2020 so then we ended up having our PR
our second daughter and then I left like
six days later and moved over and then
she waited for the passport and then
but yeah once we got over there was It
was obviously a bit of a battle like
brand new newborn baby new environment
we're in Suzuki where it's like there's
no English speaking at all
but footy was good you know like I was
good to be back in new environment and
yeah so I was just just one of those
things like I again like weigh it all up
you know what was best for yeah
and I was already you know I was kind of
what was I then when I was 30. so I went
around NRL
doesn't get paid that much right so
it wasn't like I was sitting there going
counting my cash for me nrl's days and
he's going to Market is great but I left
literally
we get to the five five years plus of
Super Rugby that's where when you start
getting like you know all the great
incentives I literally left and didn't
get any of that I left like my fifth
year yeah
um so I was like it was just a bit of a
chance to yeah make some money
experience any culture uh play keep
playing footy physically it was a bit
easier on the body just because you're
not playing against
um big fast strong guys mentally it's
probably a little bit easier because you
probably don't need to put in as much
like sort of mental load into the into
the game so but it's pretty cool less
pressure right like less pressure from
like the media and things like that like
no one watches your games really yet so
it's all yeah you know there's none of
that pressure of you know every game I
have to perform my best or else I'm
gonna cop it yeah absolutely especially
being at the blues like Blues is a
Relentless environment in terms of media
wise
especially we just started to turn the
ship too like in 2020 we're all coming
good and like I actually love my role in
2020 because I'd signed over in Japan
and then we're finishing off the Super
Rugby season I was just like taught
number 23 every week and I was just like
oh hell is this like you know like you
know like not as much pressure and
losses coming on and just doing a job
and then by the end of the year that I
actually was starting and Buddy was
playing ten so at the start of the year
I was like oats and Bodhi was playing 15
but then body went into 10 and I started
playing 15 and and like but I was I
literally played the Highlanders game at
15 I played the whole game I didn't kick
the ball once as a 15. like I was just
catching High balls just running like
you know like because bodies kicking off
both feet like he was kicking Heats
because I was like when asking them all
last but I was just enjoying it it was
fun like it was yeah it was it was good
it all going good
um and then we had this big the probably
my thing that pissed me off the most
that year with our last round of that
season we were playing Crusaders
um in Auckland
it was my 30th birthday it was my last
game for the blues so I'd organize like
I was trying to like doing the social
organizing stuff
um so I was
I'd organize this
awesome Mad Monday it was pretty much
tagged with my 30th birthday I was just
like literally gonna be the best it was
like Sunday afternoon footy or something
like that it was something unbelievable
and then my head I'm just going this is
going to be the best best couple of days
ever and just send it out send awkwardly
on a good note whatever and then they
had that little cluster that popped up
and they canceled the last round wow
that's right that's Saturday yeah and I
was starting that game too I was
starting at fullback and I'd like I was
just like man this is gonna be awesome
like we've got a crack like we can beat
these guys finally like I've never I've
never been to the Crusaders I was just
like this would be the best like I'm
just going to run myself to death and
just just like do anything I can do in
this game like it's like our grand final
and then it got canceled literally like
two days before I was like immediately
you mentioned um that you know our
Wingers don't get paid much like that's
interesting to hear like how what what
does that sort of compare to like a
Honda heat contract oh well I'm talking
I'm talking when I came through you know
like yeah so I think it's a bit
different now I think you've got guys
that there's a couple of wiggers that
are on like over 500K
but that that was like crazy money for a
Winger like yeah back when I was coming
through it was just you normally get
guys that are like well my first year
was like oh it's on minimum and then and
then after that I was literally on
minimum like today's minimum wage yeah
you know what I mean so like after that
like my second my my second contract I
was on like today's minimum wage so like
the salaries have just gone through the
roof since I've left it yeah
but yeah I think I always had like this
including like I always felt like oh man
I want to go back to the storm for give
it a crack like when silly assembly
Valley went to wallabies I was like [ __ ]
should I go over like should I should I
ring the club see if they you know would
take me back sort of thing or
those but I just was like uh you know
like for family reason like it would be
great to come back and finish my career
here
but I just know that
like I just would have been getting paid
a bit of a thought of it like you know
it was just one of those things yeah
sounds like you might yeah
yeah I know just training without the
weights meetings like any of the
pressure of woods but made up since I
finished in July I've lost like five
kilos I'm like 87 kilos yeah
87 kilos at like six foot three I'm like
I'm actually like a bean pole and
everyone comes up to you and says geez
you you've lost a lot of weight since
you're 40 days I expected you to either
train as hard as you did while you were
playing or blow out I'm not sure yeah
I always knew that I was gonna like
slim down because a part of my career
was always like and this is the part
that I'm enjoying about retirement it's
just like you're always thinking about
oh what am I going to eat next or yeah
[ __ ] like a make sure I drink water some
of my weight's up and like I'm at like
you know it's oh it's painful like yeah
nowadays like sometimes I'll just get up
and I'll just
you know give the kids breakfast and
stuff and if I'm not I'll just have a
coffee and one eat till like midday and
I'll just be like ah whatever like it's
just a thing
yeah you couldn't do that when you're
playing no you've got to scoff back like
three protein shakes oh painful so
painful but anyway we have we have to
get to these questions this has been one
of the greatest podcasts ever but we'll
get through these huge amount of
questions that we got through for you
obviously a lot of them came about the
big man who we've spoken about a lot of
them around the Collision but we'll go
to the next one this one's from your
good mate Mike Collins
um how did you become the best
fundamental player in the game
so me and Michael Collins for a couple
of years were I was always started
right-wing he was starting at fullback
and we always had this joke with us as
like hey we've got no Flair no Razzle
you know we're like all the great Blues
backlines you'd like razzly ass and all
that stuff hey where where we're the
safe guys all right the weather
fundamentals you know no offloads kick
well pass and when you're passing you're
following through your point of Target
it doesn't sound like we we just always
had this joke that would always we're
always the safe Wars the safe guys
um but yeah me and Mike had a man I love
playing against
um MC or playing with MC sorry yeah
um it's quite funny though
2016 we won the domestic comp with
Harbor and otago we played otago in the
final
and uh
I didn't know it at the time but MC was
the one that
like he came to the Blues next year he
got signed to the blues but he was the
one that sort of kicked it out on the
full outside of 22 and gave us the
opportunity if we bring Gatlin to kick
the goals so I remember when he turned
off I was like oh you're the guy man but
I didn't mention to him until we got
closer and I'm like ah we gotchas and
and it was your fault
now he's a he's a he's a great man he's
a tear on the he's a terror on the drink
but
it sounds like it okay one thing we
didn't even get to speak about on this
was your um kiwis debut but
um obviously it was one of the greats
but how did the kiwis environment
compare to the All Blacks environment
this question came in a bit yeah
um I'd say I went into the kiwis
environment a few times through the
early part of my career so I played in
the 2011 Anzac test and then I was
involved in camps in 2012 2013.
um it is it is very different like I
think when I played in 2011 we had a
very sort of old old school group you
know we had a lot of
older guys I don't know I feel like it
would be much different nowadays
um but yeah the time like 2011 with
Steve Kearney um he was doing a lot of
good things around the environment
um just making everything you know like
more professional and stuff but
I just the All Blacks environment is
just
is like another level
and the fact that I went on a northern
tour so you're traveling as well like
is very different to like a one-week
camp on the Gold Coast yeah yeah I would
say the kiwis environment when I was in
there like Benji was like running the
running the show in terms of like he was
in his prime at that point he was like
the he was like our cam Smith you know
what I mean like he was just running the
show yeah so it's really really hard to
compare especially because I went in for
a week
of the goalie versus like four weeks in
Europe it's just yeah slightly different
um I I definitely think the kiwis
environment now is very very different
and it's uh very professional and I feel
like
this this kiwis group we've got at the
moment is has got to be our best team in
history
there are there are very good chance of
winning their World Cup like oh
I always used to go into sort of kiwis
kangaroos games like not myself but when
I'd watch them I'd be like I better be
good if we could Jagger in here but I'll
be watching their game and they're
probably going to meet in the same
semi-final I'll be watching the game
thinking like we will win and if we
don't it's it's a it's a failure you
know what I mean it's not a it's not a
bonus so
gonna be an awesome World Cup mate it is
there it's been off to off to a good
start okay next question how do you
think Roger two of us as shakes
transition is going obviously another
code Hopper like yourself a lot of
speculation around them
any feedback from the goat
uh I'll be honest like I probably
haven't watched a whole lot of it but
I've kept up a little bit it's hard not
to keep up with his transition
I think he would make a perfect
um
23
like because he can play midfielder he
can play and he's got X Factor to change
again
but I probably don't know I I haven't
watched him enough to know exactly how
good or bad is going you know what I
mean but I definitely think he could he
could easily like for the blues is
obviously
very valuable like yeah but all blacks
is different it's like a different Beast
you know I didn't even think he would he
would have come over expecting to walk
into that team you know I mean like I
don't all these people saying like yeah
I've heard a few better commentary
saying like oh he's not doing that well
because he's none of the All Blacks well
I don't know anyone in history that's
walked around with the All Blacks like
Sonny Bill didn't even walk straight
into the always you know what I mean
he's like the greatest athlete
of like in probably the greatest athlete
in New Zealand and New Zealand history
that's a it's just a different piece so
I definitely think he's got the skills
and the attributes to have a long career
and Rugby Union and
idea say he's going to make a bit of
money doing it he sure will and another
it sort of goes on to these other
questions which is sort around what's
the hardest thing in the with that
transition so
um the breakdown the rules where does it
become difficult
um I'd say for me the hardest thing was
the technical other tactical stuff so
the kicking so when to click where to
kick what to look for and then the other
hard thing is like attacking with a line
really close to you so
um obviously in Union you get say 10
meters or whatever and you get time to
sum up a situation whereas in Union
you've got to be you're literally making
the the decision before you're catching
the ball like you kind of you kind of
have to be able to know what they're
doing before you catch the ball um I
found that I found that like really
difficult it just just the like the
breakdown wasn't too bad like I don't
think it was too difficult to figure out
for me like it's just
it's I don't it looks like a [ __ ] show
there but it's pretty basic like if
you're carrying the ball you get a long
place you know what I mean like if
you're going to clean someone out you
just got to get away from the ball like
it's it's not like overly technical
uh yeah but yeah I thought I found the
Tactical awareness is really difficult
like when to kick and like and then
judging momentum and like in rugby
league you get to play the ball and it's
always generally like three to four six
like it's x amount of seconds yeah so
you can kind of gauge your timing off
that whereas in Union you kind of you
have to get your depth and stuff the
same whether you get a
and then you go forward or you stay
still or you you know depending on the
Ruck speed and stuff like that so but
then you also have need the ability to
react and push into holes and
and stuff like that so yeah there's
that's what I found the hardest like
tactical cooking and attacking just
attacking awareness and stuff like that
yeah yeah there's definitely a bit too a
day uh next question top three fastest
players you've played with in either
code
with Origins
um oh Rico Rico's
lightning he's uh definitely
he's definitely the the fastest player
I've ever played with or against is he
um yeah yeah I'd say so I never played
against Josh had a car
um Brett Morris I I played well actually
it was Josh Morris so one of the twins
Josh Morris one day at Amy Park
he um he dusted me on the outside it
made me look like a fool and and he was
a sinner he wasn't even as fast as Brett
so he was pretty pretty quick
uh GI Greg English was quick once he got
going like top end so I reckon GI from
sort of 50 to 100 would he was
unbelievable
but the fastest guy I reckoned from 0 to
20 was Billy like it it was ridiculous
how fast he was like that first and he
wanted to get over 20. his legs start
going all over the place and he's like
he's it's like he loses all of his you
you watch some of his uh highlights of
hood making like line breaks it is one
of his legs flicks out to the side like
as he's running but he's lightning over
10 20 meters like he he could step you
in a phone box it was ridiculous how
agile he was application oh yeah
okay two more questions how would the
big three go at Union
um
that's hard to know I don't I actually
don't know where cam cam Smith would
play yeah I reckon Cooper as a 10 would
be all right I reckon uh
Billy and fullback I always wanted to
see Billy play Union oh yeah winner once
I moved back to the blues and I was
watching training and stuff I'm like man
it would be so good to see him he'll be
here like giving him a one-on-one with a
prop like it's just like game over yeah
you know but the thing about those three
is that they're so competitive and they
work hard they're diligent they're like
they could make it work you know what I
mean it's just
it's one of those things they're they're
like generational players that it it
doesn't even matter if you're playing
table tennis they would they would like
just go
they'd be so laser focused I'd try to
win you know you muck around in the team
room so what I know about the M3 is that
they could transition it just I don't
know yeah where or how yeah cam Smith
would be an interesting one I suppose
you'd have to go half bet really
wouldn't you have to hit 10 but probably
get good at uh 10 yeah run the counter
left foot yeah oh
I know he could do it as well okay last
question best piece of advice here for a
water lead listener and you've already
given us plenty throughout this episode
already so
um looking forward to this
uh best piece of advice
um
to be honest this is probably going to
be a piece of advice for young guys that
are in environments like professional
environments or whatever but probably
what I didn't do is I didn't actually
commit
a lot like I didn't fully commit to
playing footy I I probably still treated
it like when I was at training I'd train
my ass off but then I probably didn't
invest enough time in myself like
away from the game so like you know
classic young guy things you know not
eating well you know
getting on the drink too much
um just probably not
probably just loving the I guess
professional sports way of life rather
than actually investing in what you're
what you're trying to do and getting
better at it so
my piece of advice would be just if you
get an opportunity in an environment
invest in it you know
um
do whatever you can soak it all in and
make the most of it because yeah that
goes quick
um and I don't have any regrets about my
career because I understand that it's
that's all part of the journey like it's
all part of
you know I've grown up and and all that
sort of stuff so I don't sit here and go
like I didn't make the most of my thing
because I know I had points in my career
when I probably overachieved and I point
to my career where I didn't you know and
I feel like at the end of the day like
I'm I'm proud of what I achieved and
whatever so yeah I uh yeah just invest
in it and take it seriously it's not
Park footy it's not school footy it's
professional footy so yeah that would be
my piece of advice mate I love that
because that that's so relevant these
days you see it all the time I see it as
a coach I see players you're like come
on man take it a little bit more
proficiently this is professional footy
there's not much a but um you can see
the difference between the guys who
really do invest in it and the guys who
don't so and it does make a massive
difference and even hearing your story
like when you switch to that sort of
mindset you switch that mindset a little
bit to become more professional how
quickly things started to happen you
made the All Blacks Etc so oh that is
priceless advice from the man over there
at the storm who's giving this advice
for these young kids coming through oh
we're gonna see some special talents
come out of the storm in the next few
years
yeah we just need the we need the kettle
I think the Dolphins coming in there's
bloody
there's a lot of competition for these
kids but then I think I feel like that's
I think that excites me the most it's
not seeing it's probably it's easy to
spot
it's easy for like
um someone to spot like the next big
thing you know I'd love to see like
someone who's just come out of nowhere
and then they progress through hard work
and all that things that we've been
talking about because they're that
that's satisfied obviously the gun who
does all that
yeah it's great yeah I think you know
I'll probably see a guy like Enrique
iuani right and I'm good masonry but got
like Riggs he has both you know he's
like he works hard he's vested in his
career and stuff but he's a freak you
know what I mean so
I give him as much credit as I do as the
guy that he's a bat lady gives a lot and
he makes it as well yeah whereas the
guys that do your leg and the guys there
with the talent who just they're you
know fluff about and then you know blame
everyone else and and that so but yeah
who who knows fingers crossed then
hopefully I can get over to the uh
Crusaders on a bit of a PD
PD junket at some point yeah and vice
versa I hear that you guys have a very
close relationships I'll be putting my
hand up for any trips over there and
hopefully catch up yeah that sounds good
mate hey mate really appreciate you
giving up your time coming on the
podcast being awesome going through your
journey uh you're one of the great fuel
code International not many people can
say that and obviously um a career which
has had so many highs and lows like most
rugby careers do but uh yeah really
appreciate you coming on and giving up
your time that all good mate cheers
thanks for having me you're a lad
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]